et moi j'ai pris une photo c'est curieux
un peu ras des sénateurs les skis mais
ce qui m'a frappé là dedans c'est ce qui
a frappé tout le monde s'est tu
il ya deux mots pour qualifier ça il ya
l'effondrement et la sidération et j'ai
l'impression que tous les événements
qu'on a vécu pendant sept décennies ont
ces deux ces deux paramètres
l'effondrement et la sidération
il ya eu tout un tas de bouleversements
qui sont passés sur le plan économique
sur le plan politique sur le plan de de
la géopolitique sur le plan de
l'économie tout un tas de choses sociale
etc ou tout un tas de choses qu'on pense
et pérenne qui ont pensé s'inscrire
peut-être pour toujours se sont
effondrés sans qu'on en comprenne
vraiment pourquoi sans qu'on l'ait vu
venir
alors c'est vrai sur le plan politique
avec on a vu chez nous ça a été un
chamboule-tout de vraiment un jeu de
massacre des personnalités politiques
qu'ils soient alignées les unes après
les autres pour reprendre les rênes du
pouvoir
ça commençait par strauss kahn il ya eu
ensuite le le le
le quinquennat de hollande qui s'est
terminé comme on a vu ensuite il ya eu
de la sphère fillon et c'est à chaque
fois qu'il y en a bien qui s'amenait
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir s'installer
ont pensé qu'il a de bonnes chances de
l'emporter pas frissonner déboulonnée et
on resté sidéré devant ce qui se passait
et donc cette cette cathédrale
pour moi elle symbolise un petit peu
tout ce qu'on a vécu y compris sur les
bouleversements climatiques sur toutes
ces choses là on est on assistait là
incrédule aux incendies actuellement en
australie et on est sidéré et on a on a
quelque part on a plus de clés de
lecture du monde
les chaussures sont bouleversés on sait
pas ce qu'on va à la place et on
reste comme ça comme deux ronds de flan
avec personne pour nous pour qui est
capable de dessiner une perspective et
voilà le sentiment de sidération choix
qu'il est très important dans ces années
là
[Musique]